faux dit on est allé dans la rue pour
demander aux gens de trop duc traduire
tes paroles de chansons tu vas voir
c'est très très drôle
regardez sapé comme jamais sapé comme
jamais
loulou et buttes oui les saf et comme
jamais ce soir approche ça se tape des
barres c'est déjà bien
ça fume d'espoir comme c'était légal là
je n'ai absolument rien compris en moi
bête comme médiocre et d'être comédienne
et pour moi c'est du plus du charabia
aux modèles comme les y ai parlé hier
fait pas ce que c'est c'est légitime at
elle dit jacques lehmann ne tient la
porte juste pour regarder ton uc uc
je ne sais pas ce que c'est il est poli
que pour regarder ses fesses les gars
veulent serrer les meufs avait inséré
les femmes des mères et les dames c'est
réciproque
et ça toute l'année knight ça veut dire
la nuit en anglais elle est bonne j'en
ai un torticolis il a fait un mauvais
geste quand il a fait l'amour avec sa
gonzesse personne va me casser les
couilles je vous préviens bande en forêt
de toute façon c'est pas possible car
j'ai les couilles en or ça c'est sûr que
matin il les a en or
[Applaudissements]